I'm Matt Finn in Eagle Pass Texas uh
Lieutenant Chris Olivares joins us
always love having Chris on because he
tells it like it is uh Texas Department
of Public Safety well then I I caught
that from beta O'Rourke and I I try not
to play politics at all on this show
um but that one is just a numbers game
here so if you have buses being shipped
out of El Paso by a Democratic mayor and
you're angry about that kind of thing
out of out of Governor Abbott
um then you should be angry no matter
what the bus or who's commissioning them
shouldn't you
you're absolutely right Neil and we know
for a fact that El Paso has seen a
massive surge in uh immigrants that are
coming across the border they're
averaging 1500 a day which they have
never experienced that before and not
only that meal but we talk about cruel
and Humane treatment of these migrants
some of these migrants are sleeping in
the streets intense you know adults and
kids and nothing there's no outcry
there's no outrage
um from those officials in regards to
that but yet when Texas again we talked
about this too in order this week um
what Texas is busting these migrants
from Texas to these Sanctuary cities
it's a problem but we know for a fact
Neil that these migrants are being
treated uh fairly they are beating they
are being treated um as far as you know
within the law transporting these
migrants from Texas to these Sanctuary
cities and they are getting they are
getting good treatment once they get to
these Sanctuary cities but again you
cannot compare you know apples and
oranges as far as you know what we're
doing in as far as what El Paso is doing
because again we have to we're going to
criticize you know one party we're going
to criticize one initiative we have to
criticize everything as as a whole yeah
and again and you and I try to skew the
whole politics here but this is coming
from a Democratic mayor Pro tem in Eagle
Pass Yolanda Ramon talking about this
problem this is from the Democrat
I can tell you one thing they're not
being lied to I mean they'll you run
into them at the gas stations you know
they just want to go somewhere they'll
tell you I just want to go further up
north you know we they don't even know
where they're at sometimes they'll ask
whereas you know how far is San Antonio
how far is Houston how far is New York
yeah it's a crisis bottom line it's a
crisis and you've been saying that and
now of course we have the DEA want to
get to the bottom of the fentanyl
problem because it is a crisis they say
but what's happening at the border
that's creating that Federal crisis is
not a border uh or a crisis so I'm at a
loss
well I mean you know the only we have to
look at everything that we've been doing
as far as the State of the State of
Texas and what governor rabbit's been
doing just most recently he signed an
executive order to identify these
Mexican cartels as foreign terrorist
organizations something that's never
been done before but yet now we're
waiting for the federal government to
see what they're going to do as far as
if they're going to acknowledge the fact
that these are foreign terrorist
organizations that are manufacturing
this deadly poison that's killing tens
of thousands of Americans uh every
single year and not only that now we're
seeing this rainbow colored fentanyl
that's coming across our borders and as
Halloween approaches you know one thing
that we have to do as parents is educate
and spread this awareness to our
children because again you know this
this deadly poison is plague in our
country and nothing's being done about
it now we can do all we can as a state
to go after these organizations here in
the state of Texas but again the federal
government to step in they need to put
pressure on the Mexican Government to go
after these Mexican cartels to stop this
drug this lethal poison fermented in our
country
while uh Lieutenant Chris olivar is
always good singer Chris thank you for
taking the time on the weekend I know
you have it thank you it was a pleasure
seven job on the 24 7 headache I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm aimsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis